und jetzt ist es passiert in corona
deutschland macht jeder was er will
ja klar offiziell ist infektionsschutz
ohnehin sache der bundesländer aber
diese woche konnten sie sich mit berlin
wirklich nur noch auf einen
minimalkompromiss einigen kontakt
beschränkungen bis ende juni
ansonsten sagt die kanzlerin ich bin
raus mike drop macht euren quatsch doch
alleine so aber was ist neu im
öffentlichen raum dürfen sich bald bis
zu zehn personen treffen kriege ich im
leben nicht zusammen und im privaten
raum kein mensch will wohnungen durch
schnüffeln das ist ja im vollkommen
zeichen frage aber dass man menschen
sagt passt auf gerade wenn ihr ganz eng
zusammen sitzt und vielleicht eine fette
party feiert die fenster nicht aufmacht
braucht und dann noch auf engstem raum
vielleicht alkohol trinkt dann kommt die
herbergsmutter und sagt in zehn minuten
ist schlecht aus sonst hat der us
kirmesfreunde merkel warnt also vor wie
wir das täten
denn auftreten wird gern mal zu heißen
scheiben eine kesse sohle aufs parkett
gelegt ich verstehe ihren frust wirklich
sie spürt die zunehmende sorglosigkeit
im land und dann war da ja noch die
sache mit thüringens ministerpräsident
ramelow
ja der will corona vorschriften nicht
mehr von polizei und ordnungsamt
durchsetzen lassen gebe es statt verbote
dachte man aber dann irgendwie doch
nicht ich kann nicht mehr folgen
das land thüringen will die allgemeinen
corona beschränkungen beenden sämtliche
schutzvorschriften abschaffen
die allgemeinen chor ohne
einschränkungen in zwei wochen komplett
aufheben heißt also keinen mundschutz
mehr und auch keine kontakt
beschränkungen deswegen werde ich auch
dem kabinett vorschlagen dass zum
beispiel in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
weiterhin der mund- und nasenschutz
bleiben soll genau das habe ich auch
gedacht bestimmt wollte herr ramelow das
gar nicht aber was hängen bleibt ist im
günstigsten fall verwirrung im
schlimmsten fall sagen noch mehr siehst
du ist alles gar nicht so gefährlich
modus sonderweg er will die
verantwortung mittelfristig komplett in
landkreisen überlassen vom krisenmodus
sagt er in den regel modus so oder so
der mann fühlt sich offensichtlich
missverstanden also ich habe niemand
gesagt reißt euch die mund nasenschutz
bedeckung ab und küsst euch ganz im
gegenteil ich warne dringend davor
wildfremde menschen zu küssen
spiesser wasser da angeschoben hat
kriegt er jetzt nicht mehr eingefangen
ist zu spät in weimar knutschen sogar
goethe und schiller
jajaja grundrechts einschränkungen
müssen weiter gut begründet sein und
thüringen hat wenig corona fälle alles
richtig aber wie die letzten ausbrüche
in hessen oder niedersachsen beweisen
das kann sich rasch ändern es gibt
keinen impfstoff kein medikament immer
noch keine app und trotzdem ist das
lockerungs rennen der länder längst in
vollem gange in sachsen will man die
fesseln ebenfalls nochmal locker obwohl
man sich bereits als vorreiter sieht wir
haben mehr lockerungen wir haben mehr
freiheiten als jedes andere deutsche
bundesland koserow hin eben zu locker
stu bundesland der welt nach sachs und
jetzt dabei sorgen die nächste ford
gedrückt wird freunde ja jeder jeder von
uns hat ja die sehnsucht nach mehr
normalität ist mit händen zu greifen und
menschlich aber wie soll der arme bürger
da im einzelnen jetzt noch durchblicken
es geht immer schneller beispiel ab juni
dürfen in bayern wohl bis zu fünf
besoffene csu-politiker in einem auto
fahren sofern sie demselben ortsverein
angehören im saarland dürfen schon ab
nächster woche sämtliche bewohner wieder
an einem ort sein weil sie im saarland
ja eine familie sind anders als in
sachsen da können sich gerade mal zehn
personen treffen und auch nur um ein
flüchtlingsheim anzuzünden
die heute show wo alte klischees niemals
sterben ja gerade an langen wochenenden
wie diesem oder am letzten wo die
menschen bei sonnenschein alle an
dieselbe
orte wollen ist es natürlich so schwer
sich an abstandsregeln zu halten wie
soll das immer geht und es kommen ja
neue regeln dazu
jetzt hat sich sogar und das ist
ausdrücklich kein witz von mir
der berufsverband erotische und sexuelle
dienstleistungen ein eigenes hygiene
konzept ausgedacht erotische handlungen
sollen nur mit mund nasenschutz erfolgen
maximal zwei menschen dürfen beteiligt
sein
zwischen den köpfen der beiden muss ein
abstand von einer unterarm länge
eingehalten werden
daher muss der raum zehn minuten
gelüftet werden und der kunde muss seine
kontaktdaten hinterlassen
gut dass mit den kontaktdaten das könnte
ein problem werden wenn der ehemann dann
plötzlich eine weihnachtskarte aus dem
puff kriegt schwer zu erklären sex mit
maximal zwei personen wird nur umständen
aber hilft ja nix niemand will eine
spaßbremse sein keiner will das aber vor
allem der gottesdienst neulich in
frankfurt haben sie bestimmt gelesen
dieser gottesdienst beweis doch wie
fragil die lage ist
die haben da ohne masken gesungen in
ihrer rosa wolke zack mehr als 200
infizierte stand heute eher solche super
special events sind wohl die größte
gefahr
dann lieber einer von diesen tollen
neuen auto gottesdiensten die es jetzt
überall gibt da wirst du wegen einer
frischen luft gesegnet ist viel sicherer
und am ende machen sind wir sogar noch
die scheibe sauber meine besser geht es
ja wohl gar nicht besser geht es nicht
bodo ramelow setzt also mehr auf das
prinzip eigenverantwortung dahinter
steht ein menschenbild das man natürlich
nur begrüßen kann klar die frage ist
allerdings riskieren wir dazu fiel bei
diesen besonders tückischen und
besonders ansteckenden virus ich leite
die mal weiter an dr alexander wipprecht
chef der virologie an der uniklinik köln
komme ich ungelegen bitte wir lösen hier
nur gerade unsere abteilung auf hat sich
nämlich herausgestellt die deutschen
mögen keine virologen mehr nur am anfang
von corona von uns ja alles super da hat
mir noch eigene podcast groupies koks
und jetzt kriege ich ein tachometer post
keinen bock mehr drauf
ja aber das ist doch nur eine handvoll
spieler deswegen darf man doch nicht
aufgeben der dr.web recht darf man nicht
lesen weil die bild zeitung hier droste
studie über ansteckende kinder grob
falsch war sie gar nicht egal sie wollen
ihn fertigmachen hier schlagzeile von
morgen thorsten hundewelpen übertragen
corona alle einschläfern inzwischen
kriegt er morddrohungen also ganz
ehrlich das ist es nicht wert nicht nein
wir machen jetzt einfach irgendwas
anderes ist auch völlig egal was wir zum
beispiel mein kollege lehrstuhl in
oxford und yale hat sich auf eine neue
stelle beworben
der wird jetzt bademeister einem
spaßbades beschriften bezahlen aber die
leute mögen also ist gut lothar lenkt
mich alles da kann nicht mal schlimm
ja ja die leute die leute hassen
wissenschaftler die schlechte
nachrichten überbringen und deshalb
produziere ich jetzt noch forschung die
gute laune machen hier zum beispiel eine
neue studie ein pfund fleisch wo es am
tag hilft gegen haushalt so das wollen
die fans oder ein neues experiment
arbeitstitel rauchen in der
schwangerschaft macht kinder auch begabt
ist kann auch sein das muss man mal
ausprobieren oder also herr doktor die
große mehrheit der deutschen ist
vernunft begabt und auch nicht
wissenschafts feindlich richtig aber bei
einer pandemie reicht eben eine hand
voll doof um alle mitreißen da draußen
sind leute die glauben grundsätzlich
nicht an mir
wir wissen ja überhaupt noch gar nicht
ob es das sage ich jetzt mal ganz
ketzerisch als virus protestant und als
protestant ob es das masernvirus
überhaupt gibt das hat ja noch nie einer
gesehen das gibt's doch nicht mal für
mikroskope
oder elektrischen strom wie man haben
sie schon mal strom gesehen ich nicht
strom
das hat sich doch viel geld aus genau
aber wissen sie was ich mach's nochmal
bei strom gibt es ja nicht hallo leute
ich bin's der heute-show mimen ersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]